>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN ILHAN
OMAR AND HER ALLIES USING A NEW
TACTIC AGAINST DONALD TRUMP AND
THE G.O.P.
AFTER THE PRESIDENT DEEMED THE
FRESHMAN WRAPPED IN A TWEET OVER
HER INSENSITIVE COMMENTS ABOUT
9/11, THE FRESHMAN REP SAID THAT
THAT MERE CRITICISM OF HER WAS
AKIN TO THE INCITEMENT OF
VIOLENCE.
THE MEDIA ECHO CHAMBER OF COURSE
WAS QUICK TO HIGHLIGHT HER
CONCERN.
>> THE FRESHMAN CONGRESSWOMAN
SAYS SHE'S SEEN AN INCREASE IN
DIRECT THREATS AGAINST HER LIFE
AFTER PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETED A
VIDEO MIXING FOOTAGE OF THE
CONGRESSWOMAN, WHO IS MUSLIM,
GIVING A RECENT SPEECH WITH
FOOTAGE OF THE 9/11 ATTACK.
>> NANCY PELOSI ASKING THE U.S.
CAPITOL POLICE TO CONDUCT A
SECURITY ASSESSMENT FOR
REPRESENTED OF OMAR.
>> Laura: JOINING ME NOW IS
BEN SHAPIRO, THE DAILY WHERE IS
EDITOR IN CHIEF AND AUTHOR OF
THE GRANBURY -- BRAND-NEW BOOK T
THE GRANBURY -- BRAND-NEW BOOK E
THE GRANBURY -- BRAND-NEW BOOK R
THE GRANBURY -- BRAND-NEW BOOK G
THE GRANBURY -- BRAND-NEW BOOK T
SIDE OF HISTORY WHICH IS
FANTASTIC.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT FREE SPEECH.
IT'S ABOUT DOWNPLAYING ONE OF
THE DARKEST IN OUR NATIONS
HISTORY.
>> NESTOR AND SHE HAS A LONG
HISTORY OF NOT TAKING TERRORISM
SERIOUSLY.
IN 2018 -- 2013, SHE JOKED ABOUT
PEOPLE TAKING AL QAEDA AND
HEZBOLLAH MORE SERIOUSLY THAN
THEY TOOK AMERICA AND
ENGLAND.
IN 2016 SHE WROTE A LETTER IN
WHICH HE TRIED TO HAVE JUDGE BE
MORE LENIENT WHERE PEOPLE WHO
TRY TO JOIN ISA SAYING THAT OF
COURSE THESE WERE PEOPLE WHO
ONLY BECAME VIOLENT BECAUSE OF
AMERICAN MARGINALIZATION AND
THEN IN 2017 TRY A COLUMN FOR
"TIME" MAGAZINE IN WHICH SHE
SUGGESTED THAT AMERICA WAS
ROUTED AND FOUNDED ON SLAVERY
AND GENOCIDE.
IN ORDER FOR US TO NOT LOOK THAT
IN THE FACE, INSTEAD WE FOCUS ON
INTERNATIONAL TERROR.
I AM BEWILDERED AS TO WHY
QUOTING HER WOULD CONSTITUTE
SOME FORM OF VIOLATION OF HER
PERSONAGE, VIOLATION OF FREE
SPEECH OR SOMETHING NONSENSICAL
LIKE THAT.
>> Laura: JUST SO PEOPLE KNOW
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANO
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANP
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANH
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANS
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANU
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WAND
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANB
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT, I WANS
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SE
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE ST
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SL
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SS
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SA
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SO
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE ST
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SE
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SW
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SY
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SP
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SO
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SL
THAT YOU'RE REFERENCING WHERE SE
SAY AL QAEDA.
LISTEN.
>> I THINK WE...
>> WHEN I WAS IN COLLEGE, I TOOK
A TERRORISM CLASS.
EVERY TIME THE PROFESSOR SAID
AL QAEDA, HE SORT OF -- HIS
SHOULDERS WENT UP.
AL QAEDA.
YOU DON'T SAY AMERICA WITH THAT
INTENSITY, YOU DON'T SAY ENGLAND
WITHOUT INTENSITY.
YOU DON'T SAY THE ARMY WITH AN
INTENSITY.
>> Laura: BENN, PETE
BUTTIGIEG, WE TALKED ABOUT HIM
EARLIER, HE'S THE NEW STAR OF
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY, HE HAS EDGED
OUT BETO O'ROURKE AND NOW HE'S
TAKEN THAT SPOT IN THE
SPOTLIGHT.
HE TALKED TODAY ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF OTHER-RISING
PEOPLE.
>> ONE OF THE WORST THINGS
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IS
OTHER-IZING PEOPLE.
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN WHAT
HAPPENED NOT LONG AGO IN
NEW ZEALAND.
AND YES THE PRESIDENT DEMONIZING
REPRESENTATIVE OMAR IS PART OF
IT, IT'S DANGEROUS AND IT'S GOT
TO STOP.
>> Laura: OTHER-IZING.
>> AUDIT SINCE REPRESENTATIVE
OMAR HAS THREE TIMES BEEN CHIDED
FOR OPENLY ANTI-SEMITIC
STATEMENTS OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS DEFENDED
HER.
I'M AMUSED TO SUGGEST CRITICISM
AND QUOTING OF ILHAN OMAR
AMOUNTS TO VIOLENCE INCITEMENT.
WHERE SHE CAN SAY ANYTHING SHE
WANTS.
I AGREE IT'S NOT INCITEMENT IN
EITHER CASE BUT TO PRETEND THAT
IT IS WHEN IT'S TOUGH YOU DON'T
LIKE AND NOT WANTED STUFF YOU